one of the fascinating things about a
generation of students that's been
coming through the doors of Harvard
Business School for the last ten years
is how pragmatic they are and how
clearly they understand the way my
generation didn't understand that
they're gonna work for most likely a lot
of different companies they're gonna
write a career novel you know chapter by
chapter but it's not going to
necessarily be the the chapters not just
are going to be written in one company
and in a kind of vertical way at all
it's going to be much more again
horizontal and across companies across
industries and that one of the most
important criteria in writing that novel
and choosing those chapters and
navigating through them will be what do
I think makes me feel like I am
fulfilling my my purpose they have a
month these students have an astounding
sense of their own purpose and it's
great kind of well or hot spring if you
will of idealism that's that nourishes
that gushes underneath that sense of
purpose and you know there's a there's a
real element of sort of you know
organizational and financial ambition I
want to do this and this and this in
regard to my own reputation in my own
net worth but but that is that is you
know very much that's just a patch or a
number of other kind of patches on the
quilt of each of these people and this
there's a huge piece of what is my role
as a global citizen right what is my
role as a consumer what has my role as
employer what is my role in terms of the
time I spend what is my role in terms of
who I sign up with as an employer to
give them my very precious very scarce
energy and time it's fascinating how
this cohort of people and this is
there's good evidence this is not just
Americans it has a global kind of
aspects to it how it's fascinating how
what a huge and deep sense they have of
the power and and and importance of
their own contribution and some of the
thing is a generation raising incredible
prosperity some of that's a generation
raised by boomer parents
who were you know endlessly fascinated
by themselves and their children and
their reflection of their children that
way but it's an incredible force for
good that that the credence they put in
their own worth and their own energy is
important so so they have a real sense
of how do I make a social contribution
how do I use my energy wisely and and
and this relates directly to how they
define success how do I do that in a way
that I don't make the mistakes that a
couple of generations have made ahead of
me now every generation vows that will
not be like the generation directly
ahead of it but Millennials to me and my
Harvard Business School students have a
highly developed sense of what they do
not want to be they do not want to be
someone who you know goes to work for 80
hours a week and wakes up in their 40s
or their 50s and doesn't know their
children they do not want to be someone
who puts their marriage on hold while
they each climb the partnership ladder
they do not want to be someone who has
no sense of a spiritual and social
calling until they've made enough money
that they need to appease that any kind
of guilt they have about how they made
that money they don't want to be any of
those things and most interestingly they
don't really think that shareholder
capitalism as not only as its defined
academically but as its defined
intellectually as a paradigm for the way
business works they just don't think
that's the story that's not the song
they say that's not the song of the
world it's much more very graded it's
much more complicated the stakeholders
are much bigger than shareholders and so
they have a they have a new agenda and
it's wonderful to see that it's
wonderful to be around that it's
energizing it's it's game-changing it
shows me what the future is or gives me
a good good kind of bird's-eye view into
the future and it makes me question a
lot of the older paradigm that's been so
important in shaping American business
thus far and in shaping a place like the
Harvard Business School I think there's
something else though that
very important I've learned from these
students and and and it's fascinating
but it's a little bit less cheerleading
and that is that my students for the
last maybe ten years our students
they've known astounding privilege and
you know an astounding array of
experiences experiences that would have
made me as a little girl just you know
bug-eyed with Wonder and amazement but
most of them haven't known any real
failure and they know that they have
known any real failure and so there's a
kind of acknowledged for on their part
acknowledged fragility that lives in
that and I think it's been fascinating
to watch them through this recession
because it hit so fast and so hard I was
teaching last last spring right it's the
thing it's really the economy's really
unwinding and it was fascinating to see
some of the latent fear some of the kind
of almost quiet excitement that oh oh
boy the world is changing it's not going
to be so easy it's gonna be harder where
are we gonna learn how are we gonna be
tested and it's just interesting to see
that that they know they they haven't
been tested they know their back bones
haven't been built by the opportunity of
adversity and will be interesting to see
how they how they respond to this
economy and the new normal that's coming
out of it one last one last aspect of
this in a you know grain of sand if you
will many years ago I wrote a case by
Ernest Shackleton the Antarctic Explorer
and this astounding journey he made in
1915 and 1916 across the ice floes of
Antarctica and got lost how he kept his
team together and alive and the only
other case in the in the curriculum of
my course which is a stream of
interesting well-known entrepreneurs
beginning in the 18th century and ending
with John Mackay of Whole Foods and mr.
bono the only other case that got the
kind of traction as the Shackleton case
was the Winfrey case the students were
just fascinated by him fascinated by
what do you do when you have nothing and
everything is at stake and what you
learn and how are you tested and how do
you walk through that test and and I
think the jury's out as to how this
generation of people in which so much
the rests for the future will respond to
this the test of our times but but I've
learned that the flip side of all that
idealism and all that confidence and all
that sense of wonder is at least I think
with my students a sense of acknowledged
fragility